what do you want to say about amari he
was an innocent soul he loved pizza and
oranges and his favorite thing was coco
melon
and he loved music and
just running around dancing he was
always a happy baby
even when you know times get hard or
whatever and you
judge your character as a mother you
know he was always patient and he loved
everyone regardless of everything
and now with him being gone you know
it's
it's getting difficult you still see him
running around you still
see everything you still hear everything
and now we just gotta live through what
he loves the most
to keep his spirit close to all of us
and
until then one time we could see him
again
how come it was important for you to
come to court today
because this man betrayed me
he hurt me he took my whole purpose of
life away from me
and i don't want him to sit back and
think that he's going to get this
at all easy he took a precious child
away from many people
and he needs to pay attention to how we
all feel because this is not okay
um you know you can choose not to answer
certain things right so i just want to
be clear
but you know
the public is suspicious of you
you're also a mother who lost a child
what what do you want to say to address
that
i feel like
it's hard for me right now i can't
grieve in peace
i can't grieve properly at all i'm being
advised to stay home because it's unsafe
i'm not being able to be included in any
of this and
i'm the one hurting the most my baby's
gone
i can't it's it's hard
and all everyone in the public you know
we respect your
reach outs for the ones who do actually
genuinely care and
at least are trying to understand just
as we are
and for the ones with the negative
comments we're still into court
i can't is is very limited for things to
be able to be said in the first place
and the negative comments is is horrible
my son's up there looking down on all
this and he loved everyone for anything
and to sit here and see that this has
brought hatred out of people
when we're mourning over a child that's
horrible
he would not want that
and so did you believe
tyrell when he said a woman came to pick
up omari
i did i i had trust in him
and i would have never fathomed
that this would have been the outcome it
is horrible was there ever a point
before his arrest where you didn't
believe him
no not necessarily didn't believe
just started being more aware of
the signs until
on wednesday when we went to metro
when you found out what went through
your mind
my head just fell i was disappointed
i felt betrayed i just felt
my whole insides just fall out
it i had hope that i was going to see my
baby again and they
told me that was never going to happen
and again i i just i just want you to
address i want you to have a chance to
address what people are saying
and and one of the things is you talk to
a couple of reporters right and terrell
shared his version of what happened
which we know
police say is a lie now but people said
well
how come she wasn't crying or how come
she was so calm or what do you want to
say to
to people who are sort of criticizing
you everyone handles
stress irritation
a whole different type of way and i mean
i've seen comments on facebook from
people i haven't even talked to in
months
years who you have to know me to
understand
i've never been the type of person to
just sit here start crying and
let everybody know what my emotions are
i've always been a closed off person
and so me being in front of detectives
and
reporters i want to be try to be
level-minded to try to understand the
false circumstances of what's going on
instead of sitting down breaking down
about
you know not being able to really gather
all the information
i've had my moments of breaking down
every time i'm alone or
i leave it i be doing anything and just
start crying
i'm just i don't know i try to just
keep my head strong i just have a couple
more questions for you
um do you want to address leaving
amari with tyrell and not taking him to
colorado
it's okay you don't have to do you have
a support system
it's small but it's something
we're trying to get through everything
anything else you want to say
and anything about like a memorial or
funeral arrangements
we're still conversating and trying to
work something together and
more likely all those things are going
to be private
so it won't it won't be a notice of
anything maybe until after it happens
but the family would like to have their
time and have that in private
at least so she could be safe too you
know people been asking as well
why hasn't she been out here but it's
like you guys are throwing hate
at the same time and it's like
how do you want her to come out here and
feel safe trying to search for her son
or be out here with you guys if you guys
are you know throwing hate so
you know it's just it's just a difficult
situation um
i'm just telling her to keep her head up
you know we
we just have to move forward you know so
as long as she get her time to
to grieve and lay her baby to rest you
know at least privately without
any other mess you know after that
everybody can have their opinion of what
they want to say and speculate
because again and
she wouldn't be here standing right here
if
she had something to do with it so i
mean everybody's gonna figure that out
you know once everything's all said and
done
just let it be what is this like
for you to sort of here's a mom who's
grieving her child
but there's also a lot of criticism and
i have i've had my thoughts too you know
just some things didn't sound right to
me you know and i have my i have my
thoughts too as well
but at the same time there's no need for
that like we just lost a child
so she's gonna be feeling that enough
for the rest of her life you know that
that was a part of her
so why would we you know sit here and
bash her for something she's going to
have to live with
the rest of her life there's that's no
point there's no point
i don't care how angry you are none of
it's going to bring the child back
you know be mindful just be mature about
it you know if you got your opinion
you can keep it to yourself but to sit
there and say disrespectful things or
whatever if you really don't know
i mean it's why are you speaking
everybody can say what they're gonna do
in the scenario and the situation until
that day comes
like nobody knows nobody knows what to
do how to react how to respond they can
tell you all day
so that's just what i have to say about
it you know just let her
be able to grieve in peace you know it's
no need for more negativity on top of
what's already negative and bad
you know so i just i just feel like
people should
you know keep their speculations or
their opinions to their self you know
other than that
i understand again i was on that side
too but it's no
sense in beating her down
there's no sense in you know having that
mindset when
she needs support she just lost her son
you know what i mean so
i'm not here for that i'm not here i
just want justice for amari and uh
that's it
what would justice mean no one asked my
pain on that
that justice what means
he can go to bed peacefully
unharmed at rest
it still won't be peaceful for me i'm
just being honest
it won't be peaceful for me i i i'm not
understanding this is confusing to me to
for this to happen to a two-year-old
i'm not i'm not accepting i'm not
accepting you sitting in a box
i'm sorry if that's cleanly happen i'm
not accepting you sitting in a box
a two-year-old child no human being at
all
and for them you know for whatever the
situation was
i mean i feel like you treated my child
left an animal
so i feel like you should be treated
like one too that's just my opinion
what's your name jacqueline can you
spell that
j-a-c-q-u-e-s your last name
n-a-l-l-s you're like a second dad
and you guys had these shirts made yeah
we had we had a couple of shirts made
we made shirts for immediate family and
then we're going to start doing
bulk orders for friends and close
relatives who would like to
anyone that would like to support you
know anybody that would love to show
support for amari
will have you know pokemon
again in my opinion where i stand i'm
not looking for a cash grab or nothing i
don't they can have these shirts
i just want this love and support for my
son every day
thank you both